we've covered this before in fact we
covered it last year quite early on
which is one of the reasons why I want
to revise it with you because it comes
under as well as your previous topics on
storing and retrieving in a prelim
course it also comes under multimedia
which is one of the big topics that's
being assessed in this upcoming exam
okay so I figured I better refresh your
memory because it's been a while I do
note by the way that this is calculating
it does not say evaluating so that's why
in the actual HSC not only do you not
need a calculator but you actually
cannot bring a calculator in the point
is not to get a final number at the end
that it's you know this many megabytes
or something like that but just to show
the purchase that you go through in
actually working out okay wall how big
is something okay now just for the sake
of it I am going to work these numbers
out even though you don't have to do
just so that you can see like okay are
we in the right ballpark do these
numbers make sense at all okay so we'll
get onto that in a minute
now under bounce ability there are three
kinds of far type whose size we're
interested in calculating what are the
three okay yeah and image and audio okay
now I'll take it in reverse order will
go from simplest to most contacts
remember by the way that all of this is
considering it as uncompressed because
there are so many different varieties of
compression out there and excuse me
compression works so differently based
on the kind of data you have in a
specific photo
you can't reliably know what what
something's image size or audio size or
video size will be after compression
it's worth 30 that for things like set
mp3 that's an audio type of compression
that it's generally speaking about a one
to ten ratio so if you hadn't say a
forty big wav file that'll usually come
out to be about a four Meg mp3 file but
that kind of idea like estimating
compression
thing doesn't really come under this
heading this is just working out precise
you know for a bitmap image or for a WAV
file or for an uncompressed video okay
so the numbers tend to be pretty huge
alright let's start with images now
let's see how much of this you can
remember there are only really two
things you need to know two quantities
about an image that'll tell you what its
file size would be this is just
uncompressed right because they don't
remember what are the two things you
need to know yet okay number one bit
depth so that's a way of saying how many
colors does something have right because
each individual pixel less you will have
a set number of bits assigned to it
right and obviously the more bits you
can have the more color combinations
okay so there's the first thing what's
the second thing
good so resolution if bit depth tells
you how much space each pixel takes up
you need to learn how many pixels there
are as well and that's resolution okay
so just a really simple example suppose
we want to find out EG okay calculate
the size in kilobytes okay note the
units that will be important in a second
on an uncompressed bitmap
that is say well let's imagine say the
resolution of an iPad screen which is
2048 by 1536 okay so how do we do it
first let's see what I'm missing
something which is which is bit
definitely so what's the usual bit depth
for uncompressed bitmap now there's a
couple ways you can think about it right
you're going to how many colors are
there how many colors or just what is
the actual number of bits now the
standard number of colors and
uncompressed feedback is 16.7 million
okay morning so how many bits are
required to get that many colors yeah
yeah okay that's fine it's it's 24 it's
24 so let's get a 24-bit color okay so
like I said image is pretty simple right
it's just going to be this part and this
part but the only thing you need to be
really conscious of is this conversion
to this unit okay so here's what your
answer would look like your answer would
be and it's going to be a fraction and
I'm going to try and outline the
different parts of it in a second it's
going to be 2048 by 1536 by 24 so all
the back you just got straight out of
the question but remember what this is
going to tell you is this is in bits but
we want it in kilobytes right so how I
convert from bits to kilobyte well first
to go from bits to bytes how do I do
that I divide by eight right
and then you go from now on invites to
go to kilobytes I have to divide by a
thousand 24 good which is 2 to the power
of 10 okay so just to make sure you know
what each component refers to right
here's your resolution okay the number
of pixels use your bit depth now since
that's in bits this converts into bytes
and this converts into kilobytes pretty
simple
okay now just for the sake of it like I
said before let's work out what that is
that is 2 4 okay now I get sorry let's
say that I calculate this right I got 9
2 1 6
does that seem about right it's like
nine megabytes is that about right
yes do you'll think it makes about sense
it does it's I mean the reason why I
seems like that's so huge is because
it's uncompressed we used to take your
pictures they can press this JPEGs but
there's still like a few mega pads
apiece right so this is actually in
exactly the right ballpark you a month
ok but anyway you didn't actually need
to work that out this part up here
that's the important bit